nashua boudin has been plucked from
relative academic obscurity and thrust
into the spotlight by tunisia's
president kai syed
she becomes prime minister at a moment
of national crisis
the president has been under mounting
pressure to name a government after he
dismissed the prime minister suspended
parliament and assumed executive
authority in june a move opponents
called aku
fighting corruption is our starting
point we will work relentlessly to do
this and to respond to all requests of
tunisians in all fields including health
transport and education
may god help you and your team that i
hope will be formed quickly to catch up
on time lost to the quarrels in
disagreements in so many ministries that
became arenas flowing with blood
a professor of geosciences boudin has
little government experience
her appointment comes just as political
parties and civil society groups were
becoming increasingly frustrated with
the president's failure to consult with
them in the two months since he seized
power
tunisia's powerful workers union is not
impressed with the announcement
either we are all together with full
transparency and we are partners in our
homeland and we agree amongst ourselves
or we are people whose fate is in
peaceful and civil struggle that will
point towards the same goal which is in
the best interest of the country
the major political parties could try to
challenge the legality of boudin's
appointment and any policies her new
government tries to enact without the
suspended parliament consent
national boudin is in name of prime
minister but she serves at the pleasure
of a president who rules by decree so
what real power she has to act
independently remains unclear the prime
minister will be under pressure to move
quickly to seek financial support for a
budget and debt repayments talks with
the international monetary fund were put
on hold in july after president saeed's
power grab
bernard smith al jazeera tunis